- Welcome back to "Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation." My name is John Watrous, and I'm the Technical Director
for IBM Quantum Education.
This is the fifth lesson of the series, and it's the first lesson in
the second unit of the series, which is on Quantum Algorithms.
In this unit, we'll investigate
computational advantages of quantum information, that is, we'll take a
look at what we can do
with quantum computers and the advantages that quantum computers might potentially have
over classical computers.
We're gonna be focusing on what we can do with a single quantum computer as opposed to a distributed
setting, for instance,
where multiple quantum computers interact over a network of some sort.
There are, in fact, quantum advantages to be found in distributed settings, where communication and
cryptography come into play,
but we're not going to be
talking about those things in this unit.
This unit is about quantum algorithms running on single quantum computers.
Let's start with a natural question. What advantages might a quantum
computer potentially offer?
The main one is that quantum computers might provide faster solutions to some computational problems.
Time is precious, and although the computers we
use every day are pretty fast, they're still way too slow
to solve certain computational problems just because of the inherent
computational difficulty of those problems.
This potential that quantum computers might allow us to solve problems that classical computers
are too slow to solve
is really what's driven
quantum algorithms research for the past few decades.
There are other computational
resources besides time that can be considered, like the amount of computer memory required for computations,
but quantum computers can't
offer too much savings in terms of memory, as it turns out, and classical computer
memory is pretty inexpensive
particularly compared with quantum memory. So there just isn't
very much promise here.
We could also think about other resources like the amount of energy
needed for computation, but you don't actually
need much energy at all
to compute classically, particularly if you're
willing to slow things down.
So it really is the time
required for computations, that's our main focus.
Here's an overview for the lesson, which is about a specific
model of computation known as the query model.
You can think of this model as being kind of like a Petri dish for developing algorithmic ideas, both quantum and classical.
It's not meant to be a practical model that describes the sorts
of computational problems we encounter in real life.
We'll move away from the query model in subsequent lessons of this unit and focus instead on models motivated by more practical
notions of computation,
but the query model is a
very good place to start.
It's a simple model that allows us to explore the
potential of quantum computers without a lot of technical
details getting in the way,
and it also allows us to isolate some of the
really important ideas behind quantum computing and how it works.
Quantum computing did, in fact, first develop within this model, and the ideas that were
developed within it very directly inspired
important quantum algorithms
such as Shor's algorithm for factoring.
In the first section of the lesson, we'll take a look at specifically what the query model of computation is,
and in the second, third,
and fourth sections, we'll discuss three
quantum query algorithms, namely Deutsch's algorithm,
the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm,
and Simon's algorithm, which reveal increasingly
impressive advantages
of quantum computers
over classical computers within the query model of computation.
To explain the query model of computation, let's first begin with a more standard
abstraction of computation.
Here's a picture that
represents a computation in very simple and basic terms.
We have an input, which usually takes the
form of a binary string, although we could use other
symbols if we wanted to.
The input is provided to the computation, which is represented by a blue
rectangle in this picture,
and the result of the computation is that some output is produced, and again, that's most
typically a binary string.
Of course, this picture
is not at all specific about how the computation itself works.
We can formulate different
specific computational models to do that, such as Turing machines
and Boolean circuit,
or quantum circuits if we're thinking about
quantum computation.
It's true that this picture
doesn't represent the fact that many of the
computers we use every day are continuously receiving
input and producing output,
essentially interacting with us and with other computers through
the internet, for instance.
But we're not trying to represent
those interactions here.
This is about modeling
isolated computational tasks.
For example, the input might be the
binary encoding of a number or a representation of a matrix